Joe Rogan says one day he would like to
go paint you know he always wanted to
paint he never got I mean everybody
wants a damn paint you know everybody
wants to do arts and crafts it was the
funnest class at school it's so fun but
we all everybody got caught up doing the
other classes you know no I'd want to do
I would want to have like a sanctuary an
animal sanctuary oh God
the [__] hashtag are you following
huh what do you mean
are you following gold diggers with
animal sanctuaries are you on that yeah
every goal like there's so many chicks
out there it's like what do you want to
do in the like I want to have some um
free-range dolphins in our yard like
there's some [__] out there that are
like I want to help people say raccoons
are so violent they don't they've never
treated them the way I have [__] if two
raccoons [__] get near you and you're
[__]
Joe's juice they will beat the living
[__] out of here yeah that's true no I
want to have my own Sanctuary I don't
want to have anyone else's Sanctuary
okay and what kind of animals are we
talking over there and be honest like uh
cows horses okay look come on cows don't
need a sanctuary dude yes they do
whenever I ever passed a cat when
they're [__] having a tough time oh
no you save the cows that are going to
be butchered
Sanctuary
what do you want me to have you want me
to have like uh you want me to have like
Exotics I want you to have an animal
that needs some [__] help so you know
I'm saying like a sloth maybe get him
[__] hook him up with a motor skill
person or something you know or like uh
or rub a little bit of gasoline into
their first Something's Gonna help them
speed up a little okay but I think it
accounts all they do they eat all day
they stand there they pass gas
throughout a great time they're like a
stepdad they're like a [__] fat
stepdad you know I don't think yeah you
can't have a rescue a cows in it dude
yes you can you could totally have a
rescue with cows in it come on they're
getting slaughtered every day [__] we
need them dog yeah I mean yeah I know
I'm not even a vegetarian or anything oh
come on you give me somebody imagine you
see you break into somebody's property
and you steal a cow in the middle of the
night and you're like what the hell yeah
to save it you know there's not that
movie where that cow gets like that's
not so I think I like your idea and I
love your attitude but I think part of
it is just that idea well the animal I
don't know and I shouldn't be telling
you it's a bad idea it's a sweet idea
yeah no
um so so what is so a sloth I guess or
maybe like um animal needs it
well I tell you what neat animal needs
to be freed or whatever is zebras I mean
they put the bars on them [__] they
gotta [__] get those animals free dog
free zebras dude imagine walking around
where everybody thinks you're in jail no
matter where you are that's [__] yeah
okay so I would do zebras okay I would
do zebras see that kind of fits with you
too I think like here you go
there's a zebra she's rescuing it that's
kind of cool I think that's cool right
yeah but I'd have to do I'd have to like
10. it can't just do one that's fine
yeah I have to have a bunch of zebras
really you want so you want and is that
the only animal you want or you think
more animals
well I wanted cows but I'm sorry my cows
yeah yeah your animal sanctuary yeah
that's just that's just that's a backup
but where could you do that in Southie
could you do an animal sanctuary in
Southie like what was that
I mean
walking by
just smoking a Doral just looking in the
fence like oh look at these
[__] sloths huh yeah you could
I feel like it'd do well honestly I
don't know those kids those people never
see that type of [__] they don't leave
Southie I don't know they'd be like all
this sloth
this slot uh yeah they would just like
keep comparing the sloth to like bad
quarterbacks that they've had yeah or
bad pitchers and uh that they've had in
Boston
yeah it'd be something like that it'd be
good I feel like it'd be good for the
community
the community yeah sure
they don't get to see much they don't
leave you come back outside and you slow
at this [__] is smoking yeah real slow
um yeah I think that could be nice and
now I think a unique Boston Zoo would be
really great that's what I'm saying
right in the city well we got the
Franklin Zoo but they don't have much
there come on what happened they don't
have much really yeah it's like uh it's
like the bottom of the barrel we've got
like two two gorillas and then like
hyenas they have hyenas but they're in
like the same they're in the same thing
they're like coexisting it's sad they
don't even sell like they don't even
have a concession sample really
yeah no giraffes nothing oh like llamas
so it's like a petting zoo but they
Market it as it's like big but it's
really just my zoo and it's healthy like
that's what it is it's nothing they're
just there's a there's a soundtrack this
play in the sounds of like of like big
animals in the distance yeah yeah it's
more like and then they just have like a
big reptile section oh yeah yeah but
it's just like you just snakes the
garden snakes and it's always closed
because Donna got bit by something
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one